Oh, look there.
That is a clean Ford.
- Looks pretty clean.
- Yeah, it is.
Super clean.
I even like the patina
on it and everything.
It's either a '52 to a '54 Ford.
Hey, should we
go pull him over?
Sure.
Hey, can we--
do you have a few minutes to
pull over, talk about your car?
Yeah.
Right on.
Go ahead.
Ha, ha.
Got ya.
Nice.
White walls look great on it.
- Yeah, it does.
White walls with the red rims.
Yeah.
Nice.
All right.
How you doing?
I'm good.
You.
- All right.
- Good, good.
- My names' Ryan.
- Kevin.
Kevin, nice to meet you.
Kevin, this Kelly.
Easy.
Yeah.
Wow.
A '50--
3.
- '53.
1953 was the
year of dynasties.
Queen Elizabeth was crowned,
the New York Yankees
won their fifth World
Series in a row,
and Ford Motor
Company celebrated
its 50th anniversary.
This '53 Ford Custom Line
showed just how far Ford
had come in half a century.
It included a special 50th
anniversary horn button
on the steering
wheel to mark it's
impressive milestone in style.
You clear coated
over the patina?
Yeah, I did a
little satin on there.
I found it like this in a field
up in northern California.
Somebody was going to paint it.
So they literally started
doing some body work on it.
We did floor boards in it.
- Oh, you did?
Yeah.
Look at the patina on this.
Even the front bumper,
that's perfect.
Right?
And the other thing in
here we 12 volted it.
Oh, smart move on the 12 volt.
Right.
Man, this car is awesome.
To save something out of a field
and turn it into this, I mean.
That's what building cars
is all about right there.
Yeah, oh, man.
Find them, fix
them, and drive them.
I was going over
to Viva right now
and going to throw
it up for sale.
- Oh, yeah.
- Were you really?
- Yeah.
- That's good timing.
We might be able to
save you some trouble.
What kind of number are
you looking for on this?
Well, we put 76 on it.
76?
You know?
The price on this '53 Ford
was actually pretty good.
The body had a
beautiful patina on it.
But I know that means Danny
is just going to keep it.
And there's no way in hell Kevin
is going to let that happen.
So I've got to pass on this one.
Kevin, I appreciate
you showing us your car.
- No, I appreciate it too.
- Thank you very much.
Brother, good job, man.
Man, I love it.
Man, good find.